*burps*
oh hey how's it going bros my Name is
pa-da-pah~
Today we're going to Photoshop.
*Sound the airplane makes when you are in mid flight*
Brilliant YouTube idea
Number one request, photoshop a proper view.
To subscriber ratio onto your vids
ra-ra-ra-roasted?
oh-oh yeah max well guess what  you're not
belled anymore
What are you going to do about that?
You think twice about roasting me!
Alright let's just let's just take this.
Video and let's just add a zero
boom
fuck, that's still not enough *laughs*(It's never enough pewds)
It's kind of sad
Not even a tenth, not even a fucking tenth!
not even one percent!
wh- who are you *the kazoo kid*
Listen this happens to everyone on
YouTube don't be mean all right can you
photoshop some meaning in my life thanks
don't -now don't make that face
I recently discovered this new thing
i did it in one thumbnail and it's fucking
amazing!
oh ok photoshop school if you want to do
we'll see if you can do it just add a feather to
your last -ok how specific should i
be press fucking L on your keyboard
on feather type 25 or 15 or anything i don't fucking care
make a fucking circle around your
pervy face hit ctrl J hit V drag that
shit over to your eye.
all right ctrl J that shit again clean
Up with eraser tool then what you want
to do if you want to take their eyes?
duplicate them and put them *laughs* Sky
Williams father.. fighter.... of Justice
is that really meaning to life though I don't know
guess not next suggestion
*laughs*
can we put marinaaaa in Peru
right now we've mana -successfully cropped
marina Joyce out of this photo we can
successfully place her anywhere in the
world that we like
Peru
we can her next to -is that a lama
it's not even funny
why is it making me laugh so much? *burps*
hey it's marina joyce in Peru everybody
everybody say marina marina you're
in Peru now
Peru now your dreams came true
Marie know Mari know you're in Peru
marina why just have one when you can
have two marinoo marienuh amarina
ohmarinoo ohmarinoo they're all in
Peru they're all in Peru with a lama
or alpacoo *bipitipip* amagad right guys
I'm in Peru wi -wicked
oye cunt I will not take a fuckin selfie with
your mo *wut*
she's not even looking at the lama what the -sorry I
hate to superimpose this sort of thing
on people cause you know it makes them
look a little bit insane of anything but marina you're
a marina you're a marina
oh ma mamarina
jesus fucking christ
sorry about that one marina if you're
watching love you -soon...Marina will rise
there *laughs*
I didn't even mean for that to
oh my god is that lama
hitting on me
oh ma gawd I'm too shy
oh my god
I can't believe that lama
ooohhh noooooo
make my son taller
this is you know pretty intense
hardcore photoshop move here
oh wow it wow it sure did the trick didn't it
what the fuck is wrong with your
cat make my cat look normal we should
just need to-
(Epic MUSIC)
look at that you
honestly in comparison i think that looks pretty normal
make me pretty you know everyone
is beautiful on the inside (not her)
have you ever thought about how fucking
weird a nose looked like well now you have
jesus
you looking uh very good
there you're welcome you're welcome
can you add hair on me please
alright Jay I will grant your wish ok
let's just give him a beard I don't
know I don't know man
damn dawg you're looking fine honestly
doesn't look bad "ksi" could definitely pull this
look off and I don't think a lot of -a lot
of people can that actually makes him look
more intelligent somehow didn't think
that was possible *aimless highfive*
.....
OOHHHHH
YEHEHES
I see less of his face now so that
actually helps all right I'm gonna finish
this video tomorrow *poods sleeps*
*amazin sun*
okay I'm back
this is a first -well let's check out
some more comments -photoshop Sean kicking
the shit out of you while mark is
punching the shit out of you
god dammit ok this will probably take a
while but i'll do it for science
fuck this is boring Jesus Christ why do
I even make these videos
wow that looks so real(Yes it does >:D)
oh my god you did such a good job Felix
staple your eyelids to the ceiling then
jump off a chair
the fuck is wrong with you
make him happier please -I don't know he
looks pretty happy to me man I mean
simple simple liquify will... damn look at
that look how happy he is -there it is
now that's a smile -this is what my amazing
talent is wasted doing
fuck you -make her look more beautiful
she is already extremely attractive and
someone I would definitely put my dick
in -although the makeup not the best
let's give her a little bit better
lipstick
um
clearly she doesn't have an upper
lip for some reason #nolip
got em so we're just going to give give
her one transplanted from her
bottom one
honestly doesn't look terrible would
definitely let her suck my dick
fuck yes
CUUUTE -needs a little bit of you know
eye shadow -beauty is all in the subtleties
let's give her a little bit more of that
cleavage
damn yes
hell yeah fuck yeah
now let's try and make the face a little
less hideous -seems to be a bit of a
challenge -get rid of the horrible
teenage acne -i'm working on a little bit
of an erection here and not gonna lie
there we go beautiful -stunning you know
barely any photoshop involved and i
would definitely you know
oh look it's Dan
with a green screen
feel like I can make some weird art work out of this
(ARAB MUSIC STARTS)
(MUSIC ENDS)
what is happening
(ARAB MUSIC STARTS)
alright I'm -I don't know (MUSIC ENDS)
what am I doing here
is this fun to watch I don't think so and (CLAP)
that's the last one that came up on the
list -wow haven't we learned a lot here
today
pleasure to have you along partner and
as always leave a like -I forget to ask
for likes  wou- would you would you mind
is it too much to ask -you tell me
please come on just *whispers: fucken like the video* anyway check out
anyway check out
another video where I photoshop as well
if you enjoyed this one I think you'll like
it as well check it out and as always
head fist
*fin* (amateur piano playing) subs by avanish_shenoy